[Applause]
thanks for being here of course thank
you for having me you know it's so
interesting you the first kick ass which
got so much attention you were so great
in it how old were at the time you were
11 11. yeah i read the script when i was
10 and then i filmed it by 11 years old
okay and then immediately so many people
a lot of fans out there identify you as
hit girl is that ever strange when
you're out you're trying to have a good
time
and fans identify you with that role
yeah you know i'm not gonna lie i was at
a paul mccartney concert about a year
ago and this guy was really drunk and he
came up to me and he was like hey man
are you a hit girl and i was like you
know that moment where you're going
maybe i lie and say i'm like from
arkansas and i'm like visiting right and
then he's like will you just
will you just punch me in the face
no
i'm not going to punch you in the face
but thank you for asking yeah it's so
weird too because yeah
they they want something in that moment
that you can't possibly give them well a
black
eye well you probably could i could i
could give it to them i just don't i'm a
much nicer person than that um
i mean you've trained so hard for both
of the films you actually are
quite a good fighter what what are the
styles of martial arts that you've
trained in i learned tons of different
things in martial arts i learned a lot
of jiu jitsu i learned some different
stuff like krav maga i learned a little
bit of kgb stuff like russian fighting
things i learned
oh my gosh i mean just a merit of
different things and then you know you
learn all these random moves and then
they actually put you on set like now do
this one this is this one you're like oh
so that's how it goes together like it's
almost like it's choreographed it's all
put together in that way yeah yeah
exactly but i could fight someone
hopefully
hopefully you'd like to fight somebody i
mean you kind of like to use it in real
life
if you if you come at me i you know
andy get her
you ready to go
that's how i operate i wouldn't do it
you know you are
16 16 years old now
you're so uh you're so poised uh you you
seem you seem older you know it's
spiritually older is that a fair thing
to say i mean yeah i guess so i mean i
guess you know i think it is it's like
you know you're putting a business where
you have to act older but i mean the
minute i'm around my friends i'm a total
goof right like i just i'm a ham i just
mess up and
trip over myself and what about adults
do adults ever forget that they're
talking to someone who's 16. yeah
yeah no usually what happens which is
really awkward is they try and talk to
me about their marital problems
and i'm like what
i'm a great listener like you know if
you ever have i listen
[Applause]
um no but but do you really you have
adults talk to you
yeah i'm like you know god last night he
was just so annoying and i'm like
yeah you know when i was was never in a
relationship i know what you mean there
that's but you but you will sort of give
them advice even though you don't have
much to base it on yeah you know what i
have to based on is like my four older
brothers you know and they're all you
know i kind of have to teach them you
know especially i have one that's like
really macho and i'm like trying to
break him i was like ethan just like be
nice just like
be sweet and calm and like quiet he
should listen to you this is great
advice thank you tell him that no i'm
afraid of him
he's a big guy yeah he's a good guy now
party you talked about all this uh
training that you did and all the
self-defense training you you learned to
do some stuff with flip knives
yeah butterfly knives or the better word
is a bala song yeah it's all about kind
of um
it's like it's like making people look
up here while you're doing everything
else down here it's kind of crazy but i
can i can show you sure i think i'd love
to see that yeah let's take a look
yeah
shake it up all right yeah you do
whatever you like yeah okay
i haven't done this since i was 11. oh
good please don't touch me this is great
okay you see that
okay so you go like that
and you do this
and you're supposed to have more than
one right i'm comfortable with you
having just one
customer face those are cool i don't
yeah they're kind of fun you can just
kind of play around with them while
you're sitting here yeah
so what's the next question i can't even
think
it's kind of cool though because there's
like a whole art behind it and these
guys that teach you it tell you
everything to respect it right kick ass
two opens on friday yeah uh check that
out ladies and gentlemen and uh so nice
having you on the show thank you yeah
please come back yeah really cool
talking to you chloe grace moretz right
back